NUANCE ACQUISITION:
On March 4, 2022, Microsoft announced that they
had completed a $19.7 billion cash acquisition,
Microsoft’s second largest acquisition of all
time. What company did they buy you ask? Maybe
LinkedIn, GitHub, or Activision Blizzard? Well,
it was actually a company that you’ve probably
never heard of: Nuance Communications. On the
surface, Nuance is a speech recognition and speech
synthesis company. So you would naturally think
that Nuance is some sort of AI based voice
assistant play. Something like Siri or Alexa
probably to make Cortana better. But that wasn’t
why Microsoft bought Nuance. Well then, maybe they
bought Nuance as a chatbot play. Speech synthesis
technology could be a massive help for ChatGPT to
form natural sentences and paragraphs. But that
wasn’t why Microsoft bought Nuance either. Well
then, in that case, Nuance must have been a market
share play right? Nuance must have controlled a
massive portion of the market within the speech
technology world. Well, that’s partially true in
that Nuance was indeed a market share play but not
in the way that you might expect. Nuance didn’t
have massive market share against any of the
traditional players whether it be Google assistant
or ChatGPT. In fact, Nuance doesn’t have all that
much to do with the traditional tech industry in
general. But then again, it’s not like Microsoft
needs that much help in this area anyway. And
that’s why the Nuance deal was actually about
breaking into a completely different industry,
one that Microsoft didn’t control: the healthcare
industry. You see, over the past few decades,
Nuance has built a reputation as the go to
platform for hospitals and physicians. In fact,
55% of physicians, 75% of radiologists, and 77%
of American hospitals use Nuance solutions. So,
by purchasing Nuance, Microsoft immediately
became the dominant player within the healthcare
industry as well. But all of that is just the
beginning as Microsoft has much grander ambitions
with Nuance. So, here’s why Microsoft really
spent $20 billion to buy a no name company.
NOBEL BEGINNINGS:
A lot of us probably discount
the healthcare sector because it’s not exactly the
most shiny or glamorous. They don’t have massive
product launches like Apple or Google nor do
they have the same brand or reputation. But,
the healthcare industry is one of those
background giants that’s actually extremely
powerful. In fact, even more powerful than the
tech industry. In the US for example, healthcare
accounts for over 18% of the national GDP or
about $4.3 trillion per year. For perspective,
the tech industry is only half as large,
accounting for only 9.3% of the American
GDP or just under $2 trillion. But, not only
is the healthcare industry already massive,
but they’re expected to continue growing at a
record pace of 5.4% over the next decade. Tech on
the other hand has actually been on a decline in
terms fo GDP contribution. In fact, 2022 was lower
than 2017. And given that Microsoft is already one
of the largest players within the tech industry,
it’s no wonder why they’re trying to expand
their horizons to other massive industries. But,
ironically, Nuance didn’t start off as a
healthcare based tech company or a profit
oriented business in general. They actually
trace their roots all the way back to 1974 to
a man named Raymond Kurzweil. To be honest, I’ve
never heard of Raymond till now but looking into
his background, the man is absolutely stacked, not
in terms of wealth like other people we cover but
in terms of contributions. The man is a first
class academic scholar and inventor with dozens
and dozens of contributions that companies have
gone on to commercialize to great success. Just
to give you a sense of his accomplishments,
Ray has earned 21 honorary doctorates,
honors from 3 US presidents, and is named as
one of the 16 revolutionaries that made America.
Even before he founded the precursor to Nuance
Communications, Ray was already set. It turns
out that while he was in college, he managed
to create an application sorting software that
could match high school students with colleges.
And he would go on to sell this company shortly
after for a $100,000 plus royalties which
is the same as $750,000 2020 dollars. So,
it’s safe to say that Ray was financially set by
the time he was in his mid 20s but that didn’t
stop him from inventing which brings us into
Kurzweil Computer Products Inc in 1974. Ray’s
goal with this company was to create the world’s
first omni-font optical character recognition
software. You’re probably familiar with Apple’s
live text feature that they launched a few years.
Live text allows you to copy text from images.
Well, this is precisely the technology that Ray
was developing only 50 years ago, and he would
succeed within just a year actually, but there
was one major problem. Ray had no obvious way to
monetize this invention. Worse, he was focusing
on applications that weren’t all the lucrative
though they were noble. Their first application
for example was to create the world’s first print
to speech reading machines for the blind. While
this invention did earn them some notoriety on
the news, it didn’t provide them with all that
much revenue. In fact, Ray admits that by 1978,
they were scrambling to raise funds. And as such,
they would pivot into more commercial applications
of this technology such as scanning documents into
databases. This endeavor would catch the attention
of the tech leader of the time: Xerox. Xerox had
spent decades figuring out how to convert digital
text into physical text and this startup had built
a bridge backwards. This technology obviously
fit perfectly into Xerox’ arsenal, so they
would buy the company in 1980 for a modest $3.6
million, but all of this was just the beginning.
A GLOBAL GIANT:
The Xerox acquisition didn’t really
change anything about Kurzweil Computer Products
because Xerox was a pretty chill company. In fact,
probably way to chill for their own good. If
you didn’t know, Xerox basically missed out on
multiple hundred billion dollars opportunities
that they created from laptops and computers
to Microsoft Office and object oriented
programming. Why you ask? Well, Xerox
was never all that concerned about protecting
their intellectual property or commercializing
these insane inventions largely because they were
overconfident in their photocopying business which
eventually got destroyed. But, while this mindset
wasn’t all that great for Xerox as a whole,
it was great for Kurzweil. He basically had
the freedom to experiment with whatever he
wanted and Xerox would bankroll his efforts. And
let’s just say, Ray took full advantage of this.
Instead of focusing on commercial applications,
Ray would revert to focusing on text to speech
for the blind. He would implement compatibility
for several languages including French, German,
Italian, Spanish, and Swedish. And he would
package all this technology into a streamlined
product: the Kurzweil Personal Reader which
launched in April of 1988. The Kurzweil Personal
Reader was by no means cheap coming in at $8000
to $12000 but that was simply how much it cost
to build such technology back in the 80s. As
Windows computers started to gain popularity,
Ray would bring this technology to Windows through
a piece of software called Textbridge. Fun fact,
this software is still available on Xerox’s
website to this day, though it hasn’t been
updated in nearly 20 years. But while Textbridge
lives on to this day, Ray wouldn’t stick around
at Xerox for much longer. In 1995, Ray would
leave to create Kurzweil Educational Systems
which focused on helping people with dyslexia and
ADHD. But while Ray was no longer involved in the
picture, Kurzweil Computer Products would
continue to evolve and grow. Under Xerox,
it was known as Xerox Imaging Systems before
becoming ScanSoft. Honestly, it would’ve been
in Xerox’s best interest to hold onto ScanSoft
for as long as possible. But, let’s not forget,
these are the same people that turned around
and sold their 5-8% stake Apple for just $1.2
million. So, it’s not all the surprising that
Xerox dropped the ball with ScanSoft as well,
selling them off to Visioneer in 1998. From there,
Scansoft would engage in a series of acquisitions
and mergers to expand their product portfolio
from just text recognition to speech recognition.
Likely the most notable of these acquisitions
was Nuance for $220 million in 2005. Nuance was
a relatively new company that had launched a hit
product named Dragon NaturallySpeaking in 1997.
As the name suggests, Dragon NaturallySpeaking was
focused on deciphering voice commands, speech to
text, and text to speech. Technically, Dragon is
a Windows software that basically anyone can get
if they want. But, for the most part, Dragon
was something that was recommended by doctors
and healthcare providers to people with various
disabilities. When ScanSoft acquired Nuance,
they decided to take on their name leading
to the creation of Nuance Communications.
MICROSOFT TAKESOVER:
Over the years, Nuance managed to grow pretty
large in terms of marketcap but their vision and
purpose was never really clouded. I mean, despite
being in the extremely lucrative industry of
healthcare and controlling 77% of the market,
Nuance never really made all that much money
themselves. Even at their peak, they were pulling
in $2 billion. For perspective, United Health
Group, the largest health insurance provider
in America pulls in $324 billion per year. So, it
turns out that the company that’s supposed to be
protecting Americans from large medical bills is
pulling in hundreds of billions per year while the
company actually helping people with disabilities
is only pulling in 2 billion, and that’s just from
a revenue perspective. If you look at net income,
you’ll see that Nuance has basically never been
consistently profitable. They’ve maintained more
of a breakeven financial profile earning or losing
$100 to $200 million in an given year. And this
is precisely why so many people are worried about
the Microsoft acquisiton. Nuance has historically
been a company with very noble intentions. Wealth
was something that always followed for them, not
something that led, and people are worried that
this will change with Microsoft’s influence.
I mean, there’s no question that Microsoft’s
intentions with Nuance are very opportunistic.
They basically saw that this company was killing
it within the healthcare industry, something
that most tech companies had no control over. So,
they went ahead and bought Nuance not to control
speech recognition or whatever but to win
influence over the healthcare industry. Over the
past 50 years, Nuance has built deep long lasting
relationships with thousands of hospitals and
hundreds of thousands of doctors. This gives them
the perfect opportunity to use these connections
to push Microsoft Azure to the entire healthcare
industry. And given that Microsoft has an entire
website about how Microsoft Cloud can be used for
healthcare, it does seem like this is their real
angle with Nuance. With that being said though,
Microsoft does have a history of being very
lenient with their acquisitions. Whether it’s
LinkedIn or GitHub, Microsoft pretty much gives
them full reign of how to run their companies.
In fact, it’s almost as if these companies
are completely independent of Microsoft. And
given that Nuance’s CEO, Mark Benjamin, has
stuck around, it seems that relations between
Nuance and Microsoft are going pretty well. So,
it may be the case that Microsoft is willing to
let Nuance do whatever they want when it comes to
speech recognition while bankrolling all of their
operations. All Microsoft wants in return is some
business from Nuance’s healthcare customers. And
that’s why Microsoft spent $20 billion buying a
no name company. With historically high interest
rates, the appeal bills and bonds is the higher
than ever, yet traditional brokerages haven’t
really adapted with the times. They still
expect people to use clunky bond tables,
scroll through long overwhleming lists, and even
use virtual keyboards till recently. And that’s
why we created our own modern bond platform: Silo.
At Silo, we prioritize the user experience and the
ease of finding and investing in the issuers you
know and trust, so that you too can lock in high
yields. Also, choosing a strong user experience
doesn’t mean sacrificing on safety. Every Silo
account is insured by $500,000 in SIPC insurance
and $2.5 million in FDIC insurance. Also, all
funds deposited on the platform will be maintained
by our trusted custodian, Interactive Brokers,
who has experience managing $373 billion worth of
assets over the past 45 years. Do you think this
is a fair deal? Comment that down below. Also,
if you would like to learn about how Microsoft
is making major moves in the social
media space, check out this video.